[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
good afternoon
it is Monday July 20th and on your
screen is a live view of the Falcon 9
rocket as it awaits it's 5:30 p.m.
Eastern Daylight Time launch from Cape
Canaveral Air Force Station in Florida
my name is Michael Andrews and I'm a
supply chain supervisor here at SpaceX
and welcome to our webcast coverage for
the an assist to mission our customer
today is Lockheed Martin on behalf of
the Republic of Korea for the customers
request we will not show payload
deployment today
however we will stay alive on the
webcast and bring you verbal
confirmation of spacecraft separation we
are just that under t minus 11 minutes
and Counting and all systems are go for
an on-time liftoff this afternoon
but if for some reason we are not able
to launch today we do have a backup
window tomorrow at 5:00 p.m. Eastern now
let's take a closer look at the vehicle
that will launch our payload sit in on
your screen is that view of Space Launch
Complex 40 with the Falcon 9 rocket
it's our two-stage liquid fueled launch
vehicle getting ready for liftoff Falcon
9 stands at about 230 feet tall 70
meters tall that's greater than the
wingspan of a 747 aircraft the bottom
two-thirds of the vehicle is the first
stage it's designed to be reef reef loan
10 or more times with minimal
refurbishment between flights and as you
can tell from the re-entry suit on that
first stage it's pretty easy to spot a
flight proven booster today will be the
second flight for this particular first
stage and actually less than two months
ago it was the one that launched Bob and
Doug's the International Space Station
on our historic demo2 mission at the
bottom of that first stage there are
nine Merlin engines they get Falcon 9
off the ground up to the thinner parts
of
as fear before separating from
second-stage and making its way back
down to earth for landing and it's this
part of the rocket that we will attempt
to recover for a second time on our
drone ship known as just read the
instructions you can see if they are at
station 350 nautical miles east of our
launch site and above the first stage
above that black inter stage band is our
second stage at about t plus two point
five minutes into flight the first and
second stage will separate in that
second stage will ignite it's single and
back engine that will carry the an
assist to spacecraft to its intended
orbit and the an assist to satellite is
currently safely enclosed inside the 17
foot diameter payload fairing it's that
structure on the very top of the rocket
this protects the satellites from the
aerodynamic heating loads any kind of
contamination that it might experience
during ascent but once you reach the
vacuum of space we no longer need those
bare in halves and we jettison them
while the second stage continues to
orbit the fairing halves we're using
today are a brand new set which means
we'll be attempting to recover them
today using our to recovery ships
mystery and mischief two minutes before
the fairing just set Sal and the team
will decide if conditions are good to
make a safe catch attempt now weather
plays a big factor in the decision as it
can impact not only the sea States for
the boats but also the fairings altitude
position and speed
all of which impact how the fairing will
fall back to earth and finally around
the Falcon 9 rocket is that large truss
structure it's called the transporter
erector we call it the te but te rolls
Falcon nines the launch pad and raises
it to that vertical launch position and
also routes things like power fluids and
communication to the rocket and
satellite hey I'm Jonathan sparker
Falcon 9 principle integration engineer
here at SpaceX we're coming up on eight
minutes to launch and all conditions
continue to be go for launch
Falcon 9 rolled out to the pad Sunday
afternoon about 25 hours before launch
and went vertical four hours later now
more recently the SpaceX launch director
held it go no go Paul for both prop load
and launch that was done at t-minus
thirty-eight minutes now we're currently
working no issues on the Falcon 9 launch
vehicle if we do have to call a hold on
today's launch they have a nearly
four-hour window that could allow us to
reload the ultra cold liquid oxygen and
another launch attempt today of course
that presumes that we understand
whatever calls us to hold the count and
we can safely proceed with a recycle and
launch now if we cannot continue today
we have a back up opportunity tomorrow
at 5:00 p.m. Eastern now we've been
loading propellants on Falcon 9 since
t-minus 35 minutes putting fuel into
both stages and oxidizer into the first
stage our feel is the refined form of
kerosene known as our p1 the feel is
fully loaded on the second stage and
we're gonna finish loading the first
stage in about another minute now as I
mentioned a moment ago our oxidizer
super chilled liquid oxygen we call it
locks now the locks is currently loading
into both the first and second stage you
can see the the myth streaming off of
the first and second stage tanks started
now I mentioned it is super chilled we
do this in order to load more locks into
the tanks and increase performance
typically launch providers use locks
right here it's boiling point of about
300 degrees below zero Fahrenheit at
SpaceX we chill the locks about 40
degrees colder that makes it denser it
lets us load more into the first and
second stages now we have to load blocks
as late as possible to keep it from
warming up and decreasing the
performance
we're also finishing helium loading onto
the first and second stage tanks now as
the merlin engine pumps pull the rp1 and
locks out of a chance
we need to fill that emptying volume
that we call the ology
we use the helium stored in pressure
vessels on the stages and it's heated by
the exhaust of the engines gas
generators heating the helium helps it
expand to fill the tanks now a moment
ago at t-minus seven minutes we heard
engine chill begins we're now allowing a
small amount of the super chilled liquid
oxygen to flow past the turbo pump
inlets that's cooling them down to avoid
thermal shocks when we light the engines
at t-minus two seconds on the spacecraft
side the team did transition the an
assister payload to internal battery
power starting inside of t-minus 30
minutes that work is complete there are
no issues and there are no further
actions required before launch we're
launching out of the eastern range the
good news is air and sea space is clear
weather balloons that have been released
show the upper altitude weather is good
we did after delay the t0 30 minutes for
a small rain shower
it was crossing the trajectory path that
was moving out of the way so right now
weather looks to be good for a launch in
just over five minutes as all systems
continue to be go for liftoff at 5:30
p.m. Eastern Time as we mentioned
earlier our customer today is Lockheed
Martin on behalf of the Republic of
Korea
we now have a quick message to share
from Korea's president of the agency for
defense development under listen we call
coupon was awesome saving me de Coronado
or nonunion ago and I sister comes out
and I just tourism commando camera
youngest row hang Google I TiVo
Oh juvenile in we gave our hanger target
Aguirre Muhammad are all tongues are
Washington annamund and Copenhagen
guzelman
and Isis to resembles a million and
Allah so the corona Chico salmon roe
versus i except some nojima Tessa and
package a single Amira
you know Melissa Krieger militiamen
Jeanine Jurgen online Simon's house
Ogallala courage in godavari antimony
solo maman Posada education and Samuel
Ventura hunky away sir
Rock Adama teen air was Grievous huzzah
huzzah huzzah Martin Caracol 9 / such a
bizarre Johanna non-space Excel modem
bundle Nora here comes Adam EDA and as
history sermon gamma Coco Bongo - option
happen tomorrow mocha whom Kanazawa key
honking Wonka penguin you saw me some
consensus on universe middle and Isis to
resemble Java maken-ki donation catchy
Sango Margaret since American Amira
syndrome hello Yura call nine dot and
Isis up to one belharra comes at me
we're currently three and a half minutes
from liftoff doctor nine is now moving
into the final stage of the countdown
the vehicle remains in good health now
during that video the transporter
erector strong back did reach out to the
launch position moved a couple degrees
away that's what we need
sufficient for liftoff of the Falcon
nine feel loading is complete on both
first and second stages the liquid
oxygen loading is wrapping up on the
first stage and will complete at t-minus
two minutes on the second stage now one
minute before liftoff
you'll hear the announcement that Falcon
9 isn't startup that means the Rockets
internal computers on first and second
stage are controlling the launch
countdown now the mission manager
reports the an assist to space vehicle
continues to be go the range continues
to be green for launch and the weather
is looking good now once again there's a
reminder if we don't launch today we
have a backup opportunity tomorrow at
5:00 p.m. Eastern two and a half minutes
to launch
we have closed out the first stage
liquid oxygen load F just leaves the
stage two locks loading to finish
that call-out tells us that the chill
sequence we began at t-minus seven
minutes is now complete
each two blocks loaded complete that
completes propellant loading on the
Falcon 9 stage two blocks load the last
one to finish up inside of two minutes
will now begin venting down the plumbing
lines that go up that strong back that
you can see behind the Falcon 9 so if
you see a plume of white gas coming out
that's normal see in the view from the
camera we're now finding down the liquid
oxygen lines on the strong back getting
ready for launch next event will be
start up coming at t-minus one minute
Falcon 9's will start up the call-out
we're in startup we're now pressurizing
first and second stage tanks for flight
LD countdown that go for launch from
there we go the final call the SpaceX
launch director is given the go for
launch
we're at t-minus 35 seconds and counting
all systems are go t-minus 30 seconds
stage 1 tanks pressing for flight
t-minus 15 seconds 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1
I'm one D propulsion is nominal
plus 40 seconds everything looking good
that's the call Act says m1b engines are
throttling down getting ready to reduce
vehicle acceleration in preparation for
the period of maximum dynamic pressure
in the bottom of the throttle bucket as
they call it now the Merlin engines
coming back up to full powers we get
ready to go supersonic people is
supersonic supersonic well coming
through the period of maximum dynamic
pressure boys reach maximum aerodynamic
pressure science engineer confirms we're
through the period of greatest pressure
on the vehicle continuing downrange
trajectory looks good propulsion looks
good avionics looks good
Beck detail has started an announcement
from stage 2 propulsion we are now
beginning to chill in the turbopump on
the upper stage engine to get ready for
its ignition coming up in about 45
seconds nice view from the space cameras
at Cape Canaveral as we head east out at
Space Launch Complex 40 into the first
of two orbits planned for today
this orbit is the parking orbit a
low-earth orbit trajectory that will
take us over the equator and will
eventually relight the upper stage
engine to transfer us and the desired
geostationary transfer orbit now main
engine cutoff or Mikko coming up in
several seconds followed by pneumatic
separation the first stage pushes away
from the second stage then ignition of
the second stage engine
separation confirmed make a long time
stay sup looks good and the color in
that the engine is a full power if you
on the left screen you can see the large
titanium grid fins now slowly opening
that begins about a two minute period as
we slowly rotate the first stage around
to get it ready to come back through the
atmosphere and land on the drone ship in
the Atlantic off the east coast of
Florida right hand side second stage
engine glowing red that's normal for the
M back be directory trajectory is
nominal we've heard from the games
engineer great views coming from space
we're coming up on faring deploy bearing
separation confirmed and we've heard the
call out from the avionics engineer
fairing separation is confirmed I think
you can see in the background behind the
impact the nozzle one half of the
fairing way in the distance is it went
past the camera so right now we're
coming up four minutes into flight
trajectory is looking excellent we're
right down the middle of the road power
on the upper stage engine is good
Bermuda is now getting the telemetry
from the Falcon 9 and we're getting
great views from space if g plus four
minutes and 13 seconds those are you
just joining us we had a successful
liftoff of our Falcon 9 rocket at 5:30
p.m. Eastern Time
from Cape Canaveral on the right hand
side of your screen our second stage its
engine is glowing as we continue to take
the an assist to satellite payload to
its desired orbit on the left hand side
our first stage we're beginning to a
beginning our recovery attempt on our
drone ship out in the Atlantic Ocean the
next milestones coming up include that
first stages entry burn followed by the
second stage engine cutoff known as Seco
won the first stage landing burn and
then that hopeful landing
the entry burn will occur at about six
and a half minutes after liftoff and
what you don't see pictured here are
those two fairing halves they've been
jettisoned and will take some time for
them to get down to the sea level so we
won't be covering on the webcast that
recovery attempt status but stay tuned
on social media for updates I see some
pretty clear pictures of Earth there the
first stage has reached Apogee it's
being in the head down there
we're only going to be firing three of
our Merlin engines during this entry
burg in order to slow the vehicle down
before it gets the thicker parts of
Earth's atmosphere it'll slow the
vehicle by about 25% when we performs a
stage separation that first stage was
travelling about two and a half
kilometers per second so we have a lot
of velocity to reduced great and we're
just under 30 seconds from that entry
burn beginning it's gonna last about 24
seconds
ten seconds away from entry burn
hopefully we'll be able to hear that
call out and have visual confirmation
that burns begun stage one entry burn
start up our entry burn has begun you'll
see that that the exhaust there will
grow and start to become elliptical as
we turn on the engines the center engine
fires first the two side engines fire
shortly after them so that exhaust
seemed to grow during this burn stage
one entry burn shut down all right one
down one to go that's the landing burn
it'll occur in about one minute from now
along with the next milestone the second
stage engine cutoff or Seco one that'll
be at t-plus eight minutes seven seconds
during cycle one you shut down the
second stage and back engine on the
right-hand side of the screen also
signal first stage cape canaveral expect
about 25 seconds after it's hiko one
Falcon nine touchdown hopefully on our
drone ship just read the instructions
currently it's in the Atlantic about 350
nautical miles off the coast of Florida
start a coverall guidance and in terms
of velocity of that first stage drag
alone is slowing the first stage down
another 80 percent that Landing burn
will take us back to get that last 20%
touches down safely
just under 10 seconds from landing burn
and Seco one picot stage one landing
burn startup we have confirmation of
both landing burn and Seco one awaiting
confirmation with good orbital insertion
for that an assist to satellite
deploying now no no Clark orbit
insertion and there it is that is our
fifty-seven successful landing with
Falcon 900 drone ship just read the
instructions while we're watching that
landing we also had confirmation of
nominal orbit insertion we're all pretty
excited over here at SpaceX for being
able to use this first stage for a third
time coming up but going back to our
primary mission on the second stage it's
gonna Coast about 18 minutes until we
cross the equator where we perform the
second of two burns at the upper stage
help change the orbit we're gonna take a
break until then we're gonna leave you
with a map of where we are in the
mission we'll be back at about t plus 26
minutes for the second burn of our M
back
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
also signal per meter as expected
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
acquisition of signal birthday welcome
back John is Parker here at SpaceX
headquarters in Hawthorne California
it's qi+ 26 minutes in about 30 seconds
we're going to get relight of the upper
stage engine called second engine start
number two actually second stage engine
start number two or SES two now this
burn will be a little more than 55
seconds and that'll carry us into the
transfer orbit hopefully we'll be able
to bring you a view of the engine burn
as it gets going from the map you can
see we're just about to cross the
equator that's where you do an
inclination change that's most efficient
we've got ignition on the upper stage
engine and propulsion engineer calls out
that the ignition looks good we're up at
power
now currently when we went into the burn
we were at low earth orbital speed of
about seven point four kilometers per
second this burned just under a minute
long is going to add another two point
five kilometers per second to that
velocity that's what it will take to get
the satellite and the second stage into
the geostationary geosynchronous
transfer orbit
we're throttling down getting ready to
shut down the engine
you go to sleep that's here confirming
the second stage engine cutoff number
two now we're going to wait and listen
for guidance to tell us how the orbit
works
and we haven't heard guidance engineer
call-out but looking at the data plots
that we've got from local Kalama tree
we've got a nominal orbit so we are into
the desired geostationary transfer orbit
the Falcon 9 second stage with the Annis
two spacecraft still attached we're now
going to go through a period of about
three and a half minutes where we
prepare to separate the an assist to
satellite we're going to take another
quick back break and we'll be back at t
plus 32 minutes for satellite to fly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my position signal South Africa
[Music]
plus 32 minutes it's been a great
mission so far Falcon 9 lifted off we
had a 30 minute weather delay is we had
a little bit of a shower band go by the
trajectory but when we launched had
great skies we had great views from
first stage and second stage saw the
first stage laying on the drone ship
we've done the two burns in the upper
stage engine both of them we're nominal
but right now we're getting ready for
the big event which is spacecraft
separation and it's a reminder we won't
see payload deploy today for the
customers request so we're gonna listen
in for the avionics engineer to call it
payload separation confirmed and there
it is avionics engineer calls payload
separation has deployed confirming that
via telemetry and so 32 minutes 49
seconds into flight
that's the capper we've done the primary
mission we've brought the first stage
back to the drone ship it's been a great
day took a little while getting here but
well worth it with a totally successful
mission today separation that will end
our coverage for today we want to say
thank you to Lockheed Martin and the
Republic of Korea for entrusting us with
today's flight also a special thanks
goes out to the 40th Space Wing for
range support into the Federal Aviation
Administration for licensing support and
of course thank you for watching have a
good night
[Music]